hello and welcome back to the lab where
we take your questions and turn them
into experiments my name is Mitch and
I'm Greg and a lot of you been asking us
about the next big superfood which is
kelp and you know we're very skeptical
superfood claims but this one could be a
miraculous solution for climate change
and it's super healthy there's only one
issue which is that it's really slimy
and very gross and American markets are
not interested in so we decided to team
up with one of our favorite chefs that
lovely Hannah Hart to see if we could
make kelp taste good
[Music]
what is it this is cup seaweed it's
grown in Maine all right so this is the
dried kelp yeah so this is before and
they have in the water and so there
it'll be salty and it's actually the
salt water of the oceans making pal
tasted some good old-fashioned size
agriculture accounts for one-third of
greenhouse gas emissions but kelp has a
negative footprint as it absorbs to
solve nitrogen phosphorus and carbon
dioxide we use 40% of Earth's land and
three-fourths of the fresh water for
land agriculture but the production of
seaweed doesn't require any land to grow
on any fresh water or the use of
fertilizers and pesticides it's like the
Tesla food recipe number one is the KLT
it's supposed to be a BLT but we're
replacing bacon with this cow man
lettuce el-tee
tomato indeed delicious yeah yeah wait
so there are different types of kelp
yeah this is dolt it's about 30 kinds of
kelp that people are working with but
yeah this one is particularly known for
taste like this make try it now it won't
taste like making yet I don't
it smells heavily a foot all right so
how do we turn kelp into bacon we can
just straight-up fry this kelp contains
iodine magnesium selenium the fiber and
it's rich in protein and vitamin b12 and
even omega-3 fatty acids there's a lot
of good stuff in there one study even
found that the alginates in brown
seaweed may inhibit the uptake of fat
that was so fast I would say two minutes
yeah that was berries easily easy let's
give it a try
[Music]
mMmmm not gonna lie I'm convinced if you
stop eating bacon and start eating kelp
those you may also lose weight true
you're probably already consuming Kulp
but that realizing it this is because
seaweed actually has much less rigid
cell walls than land plants and they're
rich in sugars that help them to bend
and sway during the swells of the ocean
these sugars are known as alginate
Scarah Keenan's and a gars and they are
used to help bind and thicken things
like toothpaste shampoo skin cream
they're also used in industrial foods
like ice cream and also can make the
head of your beer even better number two
is our Calvin beans which is a play on
pork convenient so we have our cow
that's been soaking to make it a bit
easier to work with and we are just
going to chop it up into lots of tiny
pieces so
[Music]
that doesn't look like dog food Adam you
know what this looks delicious man you
can taste like the fishy flame more of
the more like nothing says a natural
combination like sweet salty beans I
would say that like the taste is much
better than the smell yeah it's not bad
what if we put a little bit of the
crunchy stuff on top I just can't help
myself we've gone too far I'm gonna go
ahead and say a hard no to help him dude
yeah there are many major cities there's
a big issue because there's too many
nutrients in the water and actually
negatively affects the ecosystem but
health needs these nutrients to grow so
they actually grew up near the Bronx in
New York City where there's obviously
like probably not like the safest
cleanest water and it didn't take in any
heavy metals or toxins or PCBs it was
able to grow and flourish there actually
grow faster because there was more
nutrients so you could grow this Cup
down the street in New York City and
then you could just eat a new be great
for the environment recipe number three
is Candide Keltner we can see a little
fresh so all you really do is you take
your cow mm-hmm you have to soak this
one - how long do you soak it for it I
says it could be anywhere from an hour
to 12 hours so you just take it cut it
up and then you mix it in with the past
couple otter half cup of honey for about
an hour they need to bake it for 30
minutes at 300 degrees so it takes a
little bit of the process that's it I
didn't hang out barely before yeah so we
have our final product which is the
candied cow for us
you know what we I think is the best one
so far
will do these are my favorite and I
really could pick you but like not fill
you up I don't need a lot of it like my
food is being like I'm done I'm happy we
were able to at least make some kelp
yummy foods that we did like it's
awesome to know that it has like a good
environmental effect as well kalfa
lettuce and tomato sandwich let's do it
guys let's open that food truck thank
you guys so much for watching we want to
make sure that you know we made another
video on Hanna's Channel it was about
the science of love yeah make sure to
check out her channel will leave a link
for her video otherwise thank you so
much for watching me you try these oh
yeah I'm really happy a very very full
of Kelsey's